moving on our main story tonight
concerns a public health crisis that's
exposed the failure of american
institutions no not that one not that
one either that's a good point but not
actually this time yep there it is the
opioid epidemic and if you're thinking
hold on didn't you already do a show
about this you're wrong we've actually
done two of them but we thought it would
be worth doing a third installment
tonight anyway for a couple of reasons
first it's an epidemic that's still very
much raging exacerbated by both the
pandemic and illicit fentanyl to the
point that last year nearly 70 000
people died from opioid overdoses that
is the highest annual death toll ever
and second you may have seen a bunch of
headlines recently about trials and
settlements taking place around the
country there have been so many of them
it can genuinely be hard to keep track
but we want to focus on just one company
tonight purdue farmer whose rollout of
oxycontin arguably fueled the opioid
crisis we have talked about their
relentless push to sell oxycontin before
but more material has come out in the
last couple of years including this
spectacular glimpse into a 1997
motivational sales meeting for the
company's drug reps
[Music]
wow
that was purdue's vp of sales performing
an oxy-themed cover of shout and that
has got to be one of the most upsetting
decisions from the late 90s right up
there with give every lonely child an
electronic imaginary friend that will
immediately die and let's set every
sitcom in new york city and make sure
the twin towers are prominently featured
in the transition shots really reminds
people they're there
purdue pharma is owned by the sackler
family and in recent years purdue and
the sacklers have found themselves being
investigated by the doj and facing
thousands of lawsuits filed by state and
local governments native american tribes
hospitals and individuals and they have
spent years working with an army of
lawyers attempting to negotiate their
way out of all of it which resulted in
two major resolutions including this big
news from last october it's being hailed
by the federal government as a major
victory against a company whose drug
oxycontin is part of the public health
crisis of opioid addiction that has led
to the deaths of hundreds of thousands
of americans the maker of oxycontin
admitted to defrauding regulators and
paying illegal kickbacks to doctors it's
true purdue has pled guilty to multiple
felonies and it is weird to hear news
that sounds so genuinely good it'd be
really nice to get more of that once in
a while like no once in a century
weather events for the next few hours or
billionaire goes to space and dies there
you know something heartwarming
that guilty plea was actually part of a
much larger plan that we'll get into
later involving the company also filing
for bankruptcy and just this past march
submitting a reorganization plan that
would end sackler ownership and the
thing is this might all sound like a
major victory that the sacklers are
finally experiencing significant
consequences but unfortunately that
could not be farther from the truth so
tonight with the bankruptcies
confirmation hearing scheduled to begin
later this week
let's talk about the sackler family how
hard they've been fighting to defend
their name the details of the deal that
they're attempting to strike and why the
whole thing is a bunch of and
let's start with a basic question who
are the sacklers well the sacklers are
the descendants of three brothers arthur
raymond and mortimer who in 1952 bought
the company that would eventually become
purdue farmer and while arthur's branch
of the family sold their stake decades
ago before oxycontin was developed the
heirs of raymond and mortimer both
benefited from and in some cases
actively managed produced boom years of
selling opioids many sacklers either
worked at the company or served on its
board and the massachusetts ag points
out some of them were pretty hands-on
they were in the boardroom they own the
company we have emails and memos that
show the direct control that they
exercised over sales and marketing one
of the sackler family members went so
far as to want to get in the car with
purdue sales reps and drive around to
visit
doctors offices it's true and doing a
drug rep ride-along is about as hands-on
as you can get and quick side out there
just spare a thought for the sales rep
in question because sure they too
contributed to the over-prescription of
america and probably led to their own
local mini epidemic but nobody not even
hitler should have to sit in a car with
their boss and talk about what exactly
the weather and then when you run out of
things to say about it do what sit in
silence and then say actually i could go
for a bathroom break right now and have
him say i'm fine but feel free to stop
and then what you stop and he waits in
the car and then when you get back he
looks inconvenienced i would sooner
throw myself out of the car in the
middle of the freeway
now the man responsible for that
ride-along was richard sackler who was
actually president of the company for
years and yet interestingly it is hard
to find images of him other than that
one in fact while the sacklers have
relished slapping their family name on
institutions as individuals they have
tried to stay out of the spotlight when
richard sackler gave a deposition in
2015 purdue fought hard to keep it
private that is why in our last piece we
had a bunch of actors play him to convey
important things like the fact that he
said i don't know more than a hundred
times now thankfully that deposition has
since been released so you can finally
watch the man in action how much money
has purdue frederick or purdue farmer
made off the sale of oxycontin i i don't
know i don't know i don't know the
answer okay i don't know i i don't know
but
i i just don't know
admit it the guy just oozes charisma
although honestly having actually seen
it i think i prefer the version that we
made
how much money has purdue frederick or
purdue pharma made off the sale of
oxycontin i don't know i don't know i
don't know i don't know
i don't know how many purdue entities
are there i don't know
yeah that is just objectively better now
while richard was the most involved he
was not alone his cousin kathy sackler
was an officer of the company for years
and even claimed in emails that
developing oxycontin was her idea
although despite that fact when kathy
was called before congress last year and
asked to apologize for her role in the
opioid crisis she didn't exactly do that
i have tried to figure out
was is there anything that i could have
done differently
knowing what i knew then not what i know
now
and and i
i have to say it i can't there's nothing
that i can find that i
would have done differently okay first
that is definitely not an apology kathy
and second come on nearly a year into a
pandemic that is just an unacceptable
at-home setup put your laptop on a
couple of books upgrade your router and
while you're at it one click a ring
light so kathy that's books router ring
lights it's the little zoom tricks that
we've all learned that'll help you look
your best as you absolve yourself of
responsibility for a massive public
health crisis
but the sacklers haven't just been
appearing at congressional hearings some
have been trying hard to rehabilitate
their image and even paint themselves as
victims take david sackler he's
richard's son and a former board member
himself he gave an interview to vanity
fair featuring this portrait which by
the way looks like it should be a poster
for natural family planning in a
christian health clinic and in it he
complained my four-year-old came home
from nursery school and asked why are my
friends telling me that our family's
work is killing people which just does
not seem remotely credible for a start
everyone knows that is not how
four-year-olds talk you're missing eight
ums fifteen and and and three times
they're completely out of breath for no
reason and five complete trail offs i
call on that whole fake
anecdote but that is just the beginning
david's branch of the family was also
involved in the launch of a pro sackler
website that aims to correct the record
called judge for yourselves dot info
which is shocking for a number of
reasons first because billionaires for
some reason chose not to splurge for the
dot-com but also because of just how
petty the website is it features a list
of outlets that mistakenly used the
brand name oxycontin when they meant the
generic oxycodone including a college
newspaper and over seven hours of video
presentations in which a
catastrophically uncharismatic lawyer
attempts to disprove every legal
argument ever made against the sacklers
and purdue this terrible website of
self-serving nonsense has been promoted
by among others jos sackler that is
david's wife and you may remember her
from her failure to face the camera in
vanity fair now even though joss isn't
directly involved in the family business
she actually talks more publicly than
most sacklers she has a clothing line
called lbv or le bulldog vigne which
translates to the winemaking bulldogs
and is an offshoot of her members only
wine and social club josh was also once
interviewed for town and country which
she complained about how unfairly the
press treats both her and her family
noting that a previous article wouldn't
refer to her as doctor josh sackler
despite her telling them she had a phd
in linguistics and going on to say
they're going to regret with a
linguist and that is one hell of a claim
joss because nobody is intimidated by
linguists you're basically an english
major who wasted more time i'll
with a linguist all day long i'll show
you how do you make two proper nouns
into a double negative
joss and david boom linguist with
so to recap it is pretty clear some
sacklers have been working extremely
hard to try and engender public sympathy
but the real battle the family's been
fighting has been a legal one and that
is what i want to spend the rest of this
piece talking about because while the
details of what the sacklers are doing
are incredibly complicated the end
result is both simple and absolutely
infuriating and let's start with that
deal you heard about earlier where
perdue pled guilty to three felonies it
sounded like some good news but there
are some major asterisks there because
while the company pled guilty to those
charges no individuals did and certainly
no sacklers and that alone is a big deal
to them in fact just watch as cathy
jumped to remind everyone of that fact
during their congressional hearing the
sackler family
through purdue has three felony
convictions but no one's in jail and it
has its billions still excuse me the
sackler family doesn't have a felony
conviction purdue pharma has a felony
conviction
i'm an individual person okay hold on i
do get the point that she is making
there but the fact is purdue is made up
of individual people who control it
think of purdue like lamb chop if lam
chop threatened to kill the president on
live tv lam chop wouldn't get in trouble
or go to prison shari lewis would why
because lambchop is a puppet who does
whatever the shari lewis tells
lampchop to do now the sacklers might
argue that purdue was controlled by many
people including non-family members and
that while they're not facing criminal
charges they are still facing
consequences but here is the thing
are they
are they really
and that brings us back to the
bankruptcy that i mentioned earlier
because the bankruptcy deal that purdue
has proposed is the vehicle through
which the sacklers are likely to escape
any true accountability very basically
purdue was buried in thousands of
lawsuits and rather than fighting them
all separately the company filed for
bankruptcy negotiating to resolve all of
its debts in one place this proposed
deal requires among other things the
sackler's relinquished ownership of
purdue which will be turned into a
public benefit company whose profits
will go toward fighting the opioid
epidemic now the company claims the
bankruptcy will deliver more than 10
billion dollars in value but a few
things about that first the sacklers
themselves are only contributing around
4.3 billion to that settlement which i
know does sound like a lot until you
learn the family has assets of around 11
billion which is a massive amount of
money but i guess that is what happens
when your company makes an addictive
product and pushes its employees to
[Music]
i just saw that 10 minutes ago and
somehow it's gotten even worse
now also you may want to know regarding
the sackler family's net worth a fair
amount of it was built up in a very
particular period because from 2008 to
2017 even as the opioid epidemic was
kicking into high gear more than 10
billion dollars was transferred out of
the company for the benefit of the
family now the sacklers fiercely
maintain that those transfers were
proper but the doj alleged that they
were made to hinder future creditors in
other words to get the money out of the
company so that the sacklers could
protect it and they found some pretty
damning evidence particularly from david
sackler who seemed to directly express
fears over lawsuits taking the family
money back in 2007 writing in an email
we're rich for how long until which
suits get through to the family and
david buddy
don't send that kind of thing over email
i mean don't send it in the mail mail
don't speak it don't think it and
ideally don't receive an upbringing that
would plant the thought in your mind but
bare minimum keep it out of the
permanent legal record and if you're
thinking well okay so they transferred
money to the family but people can still
pursue claims against the sacklers
directly right well no because here is
the really insidious part well there are
approximately 400 civil suits that do
name the sacklers themselves the family
is insisting that they will only agree
to this settlement if they get what is
called a non-consensual third-party
release and this thing is
because if they get it all current
lawsuits against the sacklers evaporate
and no future lawsuits can be filed
meaning that the sacklers who didn't
file for personal bankruptcy themselves
remember are basically off the hook and
if it sounds weird to you that a company
can declare bankruptcy and then a bunch
of individuals get shielded from
liability that's because it is it's
really weird in fact some
bankruptcy courts don't allow these
third-party releases at all but purdue
very carefully chose one that they knew
probably would a few months before
filing for bankruptcy purdue changed one
of its official corporate addresses to
one in white plains new york at which
it's never conducted business and where
there is only one bankruptcy judge who
completely coincidentally has supported
third party releases in the past which
is all a pretty obvious tactic isn't it
it's not like they move to white plains
for any other reason if you look up
things to do in white plains the first
result you get and this is true is a
trip advisor page recommending a
helicopter tour of new york city which
is just incredible come visit white
plains where you can immediately leave
and go look at somewhere more
interesting to live
and the sackler's third party release is
comprehensive stating that the released
party shall be conclusively absolutely
unconditionally irrevocably fully
finally forever and permanently released
from any and all claims of any kind from
the beginning of time and this is the
list of every person and entity they
want covered it contains over 200
companies and 200 more trusts where the
sacklers have tucked their money away
this release is ludicrously broad which
is probably why the ags of nine states
and dc are still objecting to it and two
branches of the doj have said it
violates the us constitution and
specifically violates due process
because it deprives individuals of an
opportunity to be heard and yet
incredibly despite all of this it is
widely assumed that this whole deal is
going to go ahead and while it sounds
completely terrible to me i will say at
least one person thinks that it's
actually a very good thing although i
will say that one person is purdue's
current chairman this is a milestone in
public health history never before have
you seen this amount of money 10 billion
dollars being devoted to opioid
abatement and it's only available
through this plan assuming we can get it
approved and i think when people think
about it they will come around to the
notion well i might have liked something
slightly different but this is certainly
a lot better than going into endless
costly litigation that may end up with
no proceeds going to anybody okay no i
might have liked something different but
this is better than nothing it's what
you say when your dad insists on having
dinner at chili's not when you're
talking about the fate of a company that
poisoned a generation which incidentally
is i believe chile's current slogan and
here is the thing
that man is not even entirely wrong the
longer these lawsuits drag on the more
money will get wasted in court and an
increasingly large percentage of it will
go to lawyers rather than victims
because right now under this settlement
claimants could receive payments from 3
to 48 000 which yes feels wildly
insufficient but some families are
reluctantly willing to take what they
can get although i will say others like
this woman whose son became addicted to
opioids after being prescribed oxycontin
as a high school student are furious
that this is what it's come to we want
our
voices heard
not interpreted by the court like they
have been
i don't want somebody saying that i love
i'm so happy with the settlement
as i hear at practically every hearing
i'm a mom i'm not happy with any of this
and i know hundreds of moms that aren't
either in families exactly for some
families or victims the opportunity to
have their voices heard is priceless
which is to say a of a lot more
than 48 000
some have even called into court only to
be told it wasn't the right forum one
woman called into the bankruptcy hearing
and said i lost my brother tragically at
the tip of the epidemic in 2012 i would
like to speak in memory of my brother to
which the judge replied i hold hearings
on what is scheduled before me i don't
think that this is the proper form to do
this and the thing is he is right but
this also may be the last form these
families have to be heard
look it might well be true that this is
the best deal we can get under our
current system but the fact that that's
the case doesn't speak well to this deal
or indeed the system itself and if
you're thinking well the sacklers are
paying so much already what more do you
want i'm not sure that is the right way
to think about this because i would
argue that when your family's company
recklessly sold a product as damaging as
oxycontin the question might not be how
many billions is it right for you to pay
it's how many billions is it right for
you to keep and i would argue no
billions and i'm afraid it somehow gets
one step worse because the way this
settlement is structured it's actually
hurting the sacklers even less than you
might think that 4.3 billion that
they've agreed to pay is spread out over
nine years with the largest payments
coming toward the end of that period
which means they could make that money
up in interest and investments and never
have to touch the principle in fact when
the sacklers are done paying in 2030
they will probably be richer than they
are today so i guess the answer to we're
rich for how long is oh don't worry
forever david because it seems that's
how the system works
unfortunately when it comes to
accountability for the sacklers this is
probably it because while technically
they could still be criminally charged
nobody expects that to happen and it's
just infuriating that things are set to
end so comfortably for a family that has
made so much at the expense of so many
although i will say there is one tiny
positive here and that is that purdue
and the sacklers have always heavily
valued secrecy but this deal requires
the creation of an online public
repository that will eventually contain
30 million documents including
deposition videos and the sackler's
company's emails which is undeniably a
good thing but even with that let's
admit we're not getting anything
approaching justice here and the
sacklers in sparing no expense seem to
have successfully bought their way out
of this problem well not no expense
because again despite spending millions
on lawyers and even creating a website
filled with legal propaganda they still
somehow couldn't scrape up the 2500
required to buy the dot-com for it and
the reason i happen to know exactly how
much it cost is because that is how much
we spent to buy it it is true we bought
judge for yourselves.com and i know that
it does absolutely nothing to even the
scales here but it does give me the
tiniest bit of comfort to imagine that
it might irritate the sacklers a bit to
know that when people go to that site in
the future this is what they're going to
see
hi it's me the real richard sackler
welcome to the premier source of
information on the sackler family that
you can find on the internet it's called
judge for yourselves.com
but you gotta get the dot-com
i mean what
what kind of idiot would set up
an important website
and not by the dot com
i don't know
i don't know anyway if you want the
truth
you've come to the right place so click
around okay get a sense of what my
terrible family has done and uh you know
maybe we'll throw in some makeup tidbits
i don't know maybe uh how to make a
great pesto chicken anyway there's some
great buttons that you press around and
uh you'll get this somehow anyway best
of luck to you all right bye-bye
thank you richard sackler this new
website lets you judge for yourselves
whether the sacklers got off to easy
witch they absolutely did on it you can
see richard sackler's full deposition
all of our episodes about the opioid
crisis and there is even a link that
will eventually direct you to the
document repository the moment it is
launched also because the families of
those impacted by the sacklers haven't
always been heard there are some
excerpts on the website of what some of
them wanted to say all of this will be
up as long as we own the domain and this
is at least something that the sacklers
cannot throw their dirty money at and
make go away which is not to say that it
isn't for sale at all sackler family it
is available for a price let's say
10 billion dollars
you